I wonder what you think of groups like
just up oil we have in Britain I hate
those groups I hate them with a burning
passion I got a feeling that that might
be I want I want those kids that are
throwing the soup on those paintings I
want to send them here's my if I'm the
judge okay young lady or young man or
whoever you are your sentences seven
years you have to go live in an African
village out in the
wherever 200 miles from the nearest town
of any size and you are not allowed to
use hydrocarbons for that entire time
and then I want you to come back and
tell me how you like
it that's my No incarceration but you
cannot leave that Village no handcuffs
no prison jumpsuits but you cannot use
coal oil or natural gas anytime no
propane you have to go and live on cow
dong and twigs and wheat straw and then
report back and you tell me how you
think you're just going to stop oil you
spoiled little brat